they stand up for our freedom
so we stand up for ukraine we want to
rally the world
for refugees inside and outside ukraine
to support them so i hope that many many
people will join and let's have a
fantastic result for ukraine
we have asked for support to ukrainian
migrants for those 10 million people
forced by russia to flee their homes
the democratic world had the power to
help
ukrainian courage deserves respect
together let's keep working to mobilize
governments around the world private
companies and the people in our
communities to support refugees from
ukraine and indeed support all
ukrainians
but i can only announce today for the
european commission
that we want to pledge 1 billion euros
600 million of those will go to ukraine
and 400 million euros will go to the
front line states that are doing such an
outstanding job the world has finally
pledged
9.1
billion euros through this campaign and
in addition hold on in addition
the commission working with ebrd adds
another billion for the idps in ukraine
this is fantastic so 10.1 euros and if
you say that in dollars it's even more
[Music]
you